le ministre exige qu'on en finisse avec
le blanchiment dans le porno
on a notre vedette maurice vogel bon le
flagrant délit fait affaire avec lui et
vous me surveiller
le porno c'est le cinéma le plus cool à
faire tu veux travailler comme
producteur pour moi
donné partant ça vous intéresse
[Applaudissements]
c'est un bon film enfin pas trop bien
parce que le public aime pas ça si on
passe sur des petits filles moi je vous
prie sort une demi journée 1 est-ce que
pamela peut aller soit tous avec toi jeu
et bien sûr il peut baiser pamela si tu
fais pas ma part que tu aimes pas
à peine fini par trouver un peu parce
qu'on a envie de se faire une virginité
divorcer à cause de nudisme est ma femme
avait peur des rhumes
[Musique]
paparazzi la retraite on vote qu'est ce
que tu crois que et que l'on passait
faire la bringue
oh non
[Musique]
à
du coup tant elle tombe sur wii
comme on nous avait dit que c'était un
tournage épique hâtif
on a mené alexandre j'adore les animaux
[Applaudissements]
et c'est un film éducatif sur quoi sur
la reproduction
attendez je tourne non c'est moi qui
produisent
si vous loupez votre coup moi je
reconnais qu'il vous raconte
on embarque l'équipe du film d'arnaud et
sérieux qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait je
crois des exemples mais c'était pas
prévu ça va se finir ce [ __ ] de film
c'est qui ça moi c'est juju c'est une
photo ouais on vous connaît bien on m'en
restait une photo ça donne
[Musique]